ryanair stepping into hot waters after
forcing south african citizens to take a
test in a language associated with
apartheid rhinos should be careful
language is a sensitive issue they may
well end up in front of the human rights
commission with us the airline says it
asks passengers to write and offer cards
to prove their passports aren't fake
but the move is causing widespread
condemnation
it's not unfair it's um
it's just discriminatory
as far as i'm concerned it's very
discriminatory to a whole host of south
africans who don't speak africans
south africa has 11 official languages
with afrikaans used by less than 14
percent of the population after zulu and
kosa
but afrikaans was the language of
segregation during white minority rule
when black citizens were told where they
could live work attend school and own
land
roughly 20 percent of the population of
south africa understand afrikaans but
the rest don't so you're sitting with
roughly 50 million people
who do not understand africans
so they might as well have taken
zulu which is the
biggest language
uh in south africa and use that if they
really wanted to use one of the bigger
languages while not a british government
requirement ryanair has so far refused
to say if it will withdraw the test
join wolf al jazeera